thor ragnarok is a huge hit with critics
and audiences and thus ends its titular
hero off on a bold new adventure that
boasts longtime ramifications for him
his friends and for Asgard it also sets
up a new three film trilogy arc for the
Hulk who plays a major role alongside
our title hero
naturally it leaves some plot threads
dangling with lingering questions that
range from Loki's allegiance to how
Ragnarok will affect the upcoming
Avengers infinity war many of these
stories will be picked up in a future
Marvel films but some are a bit more
nebulous and may not be answered for
quite some time if ever let's take a
look at some of the biggest questions
left and answered by thor ragnarok it
should go without saying but brace for
spoilers ahead is Hulk here to stay we
find out in Ragnarok second act that
Bruce Banner has been in his hog form
for two whole years and he later
describes as particular transformation
as different from any other apparently
his consciousness has been absent all
the while with only Hulk and no banner
knocking around that is mine oh boy he's
afraid that if he transforms again he
may never be able to revert back to
banner but that doesn't stop him from
transforming into Hulk again when
thoughts ragtag Avengers find themselves
in desperate need against haleh's forces
and a giant demon Surtur now were left
to wonder whether we'll see Bruce Banner
as we know him again we're safe SIF
really dodged a bullet in Thor Ragnarok
first act by not being available to
charge against Heller with her cohorts
without being said we've got a wonder
where she's at during this movie SIF
gets nary a mention throughout the
entirety of Ragnarok which is strange
considering her prominence and the prior
two films and the series what emitted
Lee we know her absences due to actress
Jamie Alexander filming her TV show
blind spots but that doesn't quite
explain a decision not to mention her at
all
you'd think of throwaway line explaining
she was off world might have been
warranted considering she had a couple
of significant appearances of Marvel's
TV series agents of shield as Loki
turned good for good as the god of
mischief permanently turned over a new
leaf
that might depend on whether he took the
tesseract and the leaked footage from
d23 it seems to indicate that he did
but at the end of Ragnarok we see him at
a tepid peaks with his brother and the
people of Asgard
he fights valiantly in the battle of
Ragnarok and shares a quiet friendly
moment with Thor and it's aftermath
seeming to confirm that he wants a
relationship to heal he even seems to
support for taking his rightful place on
the throne as king of Asgard birth as
Marvel fans know all too well nothing
with Loki is as it seems even if is
aiding Thor's cause and Ragnarok comes
from a sincere place there's a very good
chance that it also serves as a stepping
stone on Loki's path to retaking the
throne and doing away with his brother
we're all new as god be as store
Ragnarok comes to an end the realm of
Asgard is destroyed by tirta Asgard was
the first a true foray into the cosmic
side of the Marvel Universe and has
served a crucial role in the movies
world building over the last few years
and just like that it's gone
fortunately Thorin the revenge's
successfully evacuate the realm citizens
so the casualty count is low but the
film still ends with an entire
population adrift in space something
similar happened in the comics that
landed Thor and all of us guard in the
middle of Oklahoma so who knows maybe
this is just an easy way to let Thor
ball his kingdom a little closer to the
Avengers action for infinity war we just
know that all those us guardians have to
go somewhere and their newly crowned
King Thor needs a kingdom whose ship is
that in the first of two post-credit
sequences the Asgardian refugee ship is
shown being confronted by a massive
spaceship of unknown origin we're never
shown who's piloting it but Marvel's
Kevin Feige has dubbed the vessel the
sanctuary - which means it's most likely
the flagship of Thanos who's edging ever
nearer to our heroes as the impending
infinity war is getting closer
it's Surtur dead Sirte a hellish monster
prophesized to bring about the titular
end of days makes his debut in thor
ragnarok
and the shore enough he does just that
the film ends with his ultimate
destruction of Asgard and whether his
apparent death we could only assume he
perished along with the realm
along with hella the goddess of death
but we don't actually see anyone die we
only see them disappear as Ragnarok is
an event that functions cyclically
having happened before and almost
definitely happening again someday
you can say for sure that Surtur is dead
perhaps he simply gone back to his realm
to start the cycle over again will Thor
get me or near back one of the most
shocking moments in Thor Ragnarok comes
in his first act when Heller crushes
Thor's hammer Mjolnir with a bare hand
it's a huge moment as Mjolnir is thought
to be indestructible perhaps even more
surprising is the fact that he doesn't
get me or near back by the time the film
is over admittedly part of the
characters arc is coming into his own as
the rightful king of Asgard and the god
of thunder
Mjolnir only helps him channel his
powers it isn't their source still of
Thor without a hammer seems somewhat
naked and we can't help but wonder if
he'll be getting his favorite toy back
every time I through who always come
back to me oh Nia looked pretty busted
after hella had away with it but when
dealing with norse mythology and comic
book characters practicality isn't
really a priority don't be surprised if
these two find a way back together
thanks for watching click the looper
icon to subscribe to our youtube channel
let's check out all this cool stuff we
know you're loved too
[Music]